which Florida panther would do the best
in a Royal Rumble I'll go Chucky I like
that pick who wins one-on-one
you versus the hubby Road hockey
let's say oh that's tough that's
tough he has a longer reach than I
do hello everybody and welcome to another edition
of The Jackie Redmond show I am so excited to be
hanging out with you once again this week and we
have got quite the show in store we're going to
catch up with Florida panther Carter ver heagy
who is having himself another stud likee season
for the cats plus you may know her from the
Olympics International play she is one of the
more well decorated players in the women's game
today pwl Toronto's ranata fast and I'm going
to give you what I'm calling my unofficial
Allstar Specialists if you're confused you
probably should be so stick around to find out
what I mean We Begin though with Florida panther
Carter vagy check it out career-high 42 goals
last year more than halfway to hitting that 40
goal Mark again this year Carter reagy I imagine
you're feeling pretty good about your personal
game at the moment thanks for doing the show yeah
thanks for having me on I mean uh yeah things are
going pretty well and I mean uh for our team too
we're definitely in a better position than we were
the last year going this point yeah on the whole
you guys have looked so good I mean you had that
nine game winning streak uh about a week ago you
guys were on Fuego then I mean last year I think
I still owe Shane O'Brien a bottle of cist for
saying that you guys were cooked at the halfway
point so uh joke was on me last year but you guys
look solid uh all season this year so far we are
in the middle of NFL playoffs I understand you're
a football fan I know that you played hockey in
KC but you're a Canadian I'm just curious where
your football fandom lies like are you a bills or
a lions fan or are you a Chiefs fan give us the
the Deets yeah I'm definitely a Bills fan uh I
grew up in uh pretty close to buffo actually and
uh I went to a couple games when uh I was living
around that area and yeah I'm a bills mafia guy
okay so how do you feel because they're playing
the Chiefs this weekend how do you feel about
the matchup I don't know if you're playing the
day that they are playing but how will you watch
the game like what what's the plan yeah that's
uh it's going to be a good matchup anytime those
two teams uh they're both really good teams and
anytime they play each other it's always a fun
one and yeah I actually haven't really checked
the schedule right now uh our schedule's kind
of every other day and it's kind of a bit of a
blur for me right now but hopefully uh I get some
time time off that day and I can definitely catch
that one yeah maybe when the boys get together we
saw H rasma doll lean's bill from uh watching the
playoff game with the team a few weeks ago bills
mafia they like to they like to break tables they
get a little bit bit of WWE Action when they when
they pregame for those games have you ever gone
to a Bill's tailgate and taken part in some of
their crazy pregame festivities yeah I actually
have and uh I definitely I wasn't jumping through
the tables but I definitely saw a couple people
do it uh I went to a game and uh honestly it was
so snowy you couldn't even really see the field
from where we were sitting it was a it was a
cold one but uh it was a lot of fun and yeah
those games are always awesome to go to and the
fans there are just absolutely nuts yeah they are
their own breed uh to say the very least I think
being a spectator during the pregame uh spectacle
is probably a wise choice by you considering you
are a professional athlete but you did play hockey
I think it was for one season uh in Missouri if
I'm not mistaken and we've heard Patrick Mahomes
a couple of years ago talk about the NHL needs
to bring a hockey team to KC how do you think
an NHL team would do uh in KC what was what was
it like playing hockey there yeah I had a really
good experience playing hockey there the fans are
pretty passionate and I mean uh yeah it was a lot
of fun and it's definitely could support an NHL
team I think I mean uh I think they got a a new
Arena downtown I forget what it's called maybe the
Sprint Center or something and I think they were
hosting like pregame or uh preseason games there
and I mean I think it did well it was selling
out and even for uh the team that I play for the
Mavericks I mean we always did well had awesome
fans and yeah it was actually a lot of fun playing
there I I for sure think that NH should look into
it at least yeah I think when when Mahomes said
that I know it caused quite a stir on Twitter and
then I think Travis Kelce supported it and right
now I mean anything the Kelsey want seems to come
to fruition so maybe that will happen at some
point um in the future I want to ask you about
playing in Florida because Florida is now a hockey
town I mean it used to be a running joke right oh
they don't like hockey in Florida then Tampa had
their run now you guys are having your run I think
you sold out three games in a row uh earlier in
the season which was a franchise record you've
sold out your lower bowl season tickets I asked
your coach Paul Maurice about it in November and
he said it's a noticeable difference this year
to last year it actually feels like you have a
home ICE Advantage now do you agree 100% I mean
even since I got here I think everyone was yeah
triping the fans and stuff and I mean I thought
they've always been great every year I think
I played here we always had a good team and I
mean I think they support the good teams when
when we're winning and it comes out and yeah
anytime like I go out to the grocery store or
around town I I'm getting noticed I'm on my golf
cart sometime sometimes people are honking at me
on the roads go Panthers and stuff and stuff like
that so I mean it's definitely more so after last
year's run but I mean I mean uh to be honest
I think the fans have always been there and I
mean I think they're just waiting for a good team
after years of uh tough tough uh Seasons getting
a little bit of that local celeb rub hey the the
autograph is perfected the selfie pose I'm sure
is uh getting a lot of practice uh I did want to
ask you one more question about your head coach
because last year after you guys lost in the Cup
Final Paul Maurice had what was my favorite quote
of the entire postseason he said you know as
you get older you get cynical but those guys
in there meeting you guys the players the way
they treat each other has completely destroyed
any cynicism that I had about professional sports
I mean he was genuinely so proud of you guys why
has he been the perfect coach for this Florida
Panthers team yeah I mean I think uh he brings
so many different elements to our team and I
think uh he's been around forever and uh he's
probably coached more than more years than I've
been alive in the NHL which is pretty crazy he
knows how to run a team I mean he knows when to
push us when to let us go a little bit I mean he
knows how to run a bench I mean yeah and he he
kind of knew what we needed when he came in and
I mean he stuck with it even last year when things
weren't going so well at the start we kind of just
stuck with uh his kind of system and obviously
it paid off last year uh with how well we did
in the playoffs and uh coming into this year too
it's really demanding but it's really rewarding
because uh when everyone Buys in I mean every
it's so rewarding he's become a quote machine
as well I feel like he's he's so comfortable now
as a coach in the league he's so good with the
media he's got like on liners are just ready
to go sometimes I'm nervous to interview him
actually because I think he'll say something or
make a joke and I'm not quick enough to keep up
you know what I mean so I get like a little bit
nervous every time I have to interview him but
he's the best um Allstar we again couple weeks
away I wanted to have some fun with you and give
out some Allstar Awards to your Florida Panthers
teammates so if you're cool with it I'll tell you
what the award is and then you can tell me who
would get it cool all right let's do it okay if
you were giving out an Allstar award for pulling
pranks who on the Florida Panthers would win that
award uh Brandon Montour Brandon Montour and
he won't even admit it I mean he'll go it'll be
years guys still don't know who did it he's pretty
good he flies under the radar and everyone kind of
knows it's him but he'll never uh never admit it
yeah you know what I respect the commitment to
the secrecy of the prank like if you're keeping
that inside for years I mean that's kind of what
Legends are made of um I think all right right
okay next I would have to just tell him right away
I would feel bad right away have to tell him you
have a guilty conscience you'd be like all right
it was me like I hid your shoes or whatever and
now you're shoeless at the airport all right um
Allstar award for locker room speeches or just
like getting the boys fired up in the room uh
I'd say probably Lomo the Lamborghini I mean
he's uh always the most positive guy I mean
anytime you come back to the bench and uh you're
a little upset or something he's just telling you
oh you're going to score a goal or something like
that tells you how how great of a player you are
and he's always uh there to pump everyone up and
uh just a really good teammate all right sounds
like a good hype man uh one more for you who would
who would be the allstar Florida panther for being
late like never on time oh that's a tough one
uh I I'll I'll have to give it to Ryan because
I think last year he missed a couple Me Maybe
One in Tampa his alarm clock didn't go off and
I think uh he he really likes his sleep okay
listen I I empathize that I have to set like
five alarms to make sure that I get up if I have
something super important in the morning um okay
we got a couple more rapid fire questions and
then we're going to let you go okay so these
ones we can just snap them real quick so number
one what is carder Heggy's go-to coffee order
uh just milk just oh black Cofe milk
black coffee little splash of milk I
gotta which Florida panther would
do the best in a Royal Rumble WWE
style I'll go Chucky I like that
pick if you could have a cameo
on any TV show past or present what show would it
be uh a cameo like a like an appearance on
a show so you would you would be have like
a cameo on like Entourage or something you'd
be in a scene I want to be on Yellowstone oh
that's a good okay okay do you have a cowboy
hat ready to go yeah yeah I'd have to go get
a cowboy hat and hang out on the Dutton Ranch
yeah maybe get maybe get some horse lessons
horse riding lessons before you go yeah
most famous person you've ever met through
hockey uh I think I uh I met Michael Jordan
actually uh this summer at a concert they
can it was at our Arena so they let me uh say
hi to them okay that's I you you said that so
nonchalant you're just like oh I guess I mean
I met Michael Jordan I didn't even know what to
say to him yeah really do you remember what you
said or were you just like hey nice to meet you
and like that was it I was just hey nice to meet
you and then that was pretty much I mean yeah tell
me you got a phot photo though no I was actually
pretty nervous I actually didn't even ask for a
photo I wasn't even thinking about that I was
kind of star trck oh now oh my gosh that's one
you're gonna remember forever because it's after
was telling me that you're gonna be like to your
grandkids you're be like no no I did I met Michael
Jordan I just don't have photographic evidence oh
Carter thank you for being a good sportman I
really appreciate it um best of luck the rest
of the way you guys look so good um you are the
cats but wasn't it you guys in the playoffs that
had that dog in them was that you guys that had
that sort of rally C the yeah the bone yeah yeah
that's it all right thank you so much for the
time best of luck the rest of the way thanks
Jackie I appreciate in two weeks the NHL takes
over Toronto for All-Star Weekend where the best
of the best we get together and have some fun but
listen some people are a jack of all trades While
others are a master of one and of often times that
one thing is something that doesn't exactly show
up on the score sheet but it doesn't make it any
less important hockey needs its Checkers its face
off guys it's players who go into the corners
elbows up and come out with the puck you know
what I'm saying there's Specialists and a lot of
times it's those players that work their way to
becoming fan favorites so with that here are my
officially unofficial Allstar Specialists let's
start with Puck battles who doesn't love a player
that battles on the boards or in the corner and
always seems to come out with the puck I mean
these are the studs that help you win when the
game gets harder and this year no forward has won
more Puck battles than sha couturier he's got 167
at the time of this recording and let me tell you
Coots is back and a major reason the Flyers are
relevant again but that's not news to anyone in
Philly and while we're on the topic of comeback
players yall know I love a defenseman that shuts
it down which brings us to dzone denials this
is one of my favorite Advanced stats because
it tracks who's stepping up and stopping the
opposition from entering the Zone these are the
guys who break up plays at the Blue Line and lock
it down leading all defensemen in dzone denials
this year is one Colton Paro yes the same Paro
who helped the St Louis Blues win a Stanley Cup
in 2019 after a brutal back injury he too appears
to be back and for what it's worth pero is also
first in Puck battles one for dmen okay next up
we're talking penalties drawing them not taking
them this isn't fantasy you don't get points for
pims if you draw a lot of penalties though you're
probably one of two things you're either so good
the only chance a Defender has it stopping you
is by breaking a rule AKA Conor McDavid or or
you're such a pest that you just simply annoy
the opposition into taking a penalty against
you someone like you know Brad Maran so here's
how it breaks down this season Brady kachuck has
drawn the most penalties in the NHL but he's also
taken quite a few he might want to work on that
now as m cadri is second in penalties drawn with
26 and get this he's only taken 11 which gives him
a differential of 15 in a good way yeah cadri the
same player that got traded by the Maple Leafs for
discipline issues not anymore guess he's evolved
and in our final Allstar specialist category we
love a blocked shot artist in this house the dudes
who sacrificed themselves all season long For the
Love of the Game and leading that category this
season no surprise it's Jacob trouba I know I
know he's a polarizing figure people don't like
this guy outside of New York but you can't deny
he makes a pretty big and solid impact in more
ways than one all right those are my Allstar
Specialists halfway through this season but I
want to know who you guys are loving give me your
Specialists who's somebody that is dominating
a certain aspect of the game that maybe isn't
getting a ton of Love drop it in the comments
let me know I want to hear you and while we're
on the topic of Allstars you can see our next
guest at Allstar Weekend in Toronto as part of
the pwl three Onre showcase but if you are a fan
of the women's game you already know her she is
ranata fast she joins us now thank you so much for
hanging out with me on this edition of the show
I just want to start by saying congratulations
on everything that has been happening over the
last few months the pwhl is off to a rocking start
you must be thrilled yeah thanks for having me but
it's been such an incredible couple weeks here as
the leagues launched we've been in training camp
uh since the beginning of November and just the
support we've had from the community in Toronto
but even uh in North America and worldwide of
just the pwhl in the launch has been really
amazing and the players are so thrilled with how
professional the environment has been and the
pace of play has been incredible so it's just
been such a special a couple weeks you know as
someone on the outside who grew up playing hockey
in Canada and is obviously a passionate uh fan of
the game both men's and women's I feel like it's
been emotional for me but I'm not in it like I
cannot imagine what it must be like for you and
the other girls in the room when you were a kid
could you have ever imagined that we would get
to this point in in your lifetime honestly not
at all like growing up as a kid the only thing I
really thought of was the Olympics that's all I
ever dreamt of and I never thought it would even
be possible to play in a professional League uh so
to be a part of the launch of it to help create it
has been so amazing just to see what it takes to
put something like this together but I think one
of the coolest Parts about it is like knowing that
this is g to last forever like all of us who are a
part of it now all of the fans who get to witness
what's happening and and these historic moments
like we get to watch this league grow for years
and years to come and that's honestly what I'm
most looking forward to I'm so grateful to have
the opportunity to play in it but I'm so excited
to just watch it Grow from year to year I mean
you've done a lot in your career already you've
played in the Olympics you've represented Canada
you're very well decorated were you nervous at
all though for the first game I mean you you I'm
sure didn't know what to expect in terms of the
crowds yeah honestly it was it was a different
type of nerves like you said like playing in an
Olympic gold medal final game obviously you have
some nerves there but this was different like
I wasn't nervous for my game play um or for my
team I was just nervous for like had butterflies
in my stomach for knowing how big of a moment
this was for our Sport and for the future of our
game so yeah it was kind of like a weird feeling
going into game one uh and stepping on the ice in
front of like our fans was so special just to feel
the support and being like people are showing
up here for us they they want to be a part of
history and it was just really cool but not your
typical game day nerves yeah I I bet it was it
was vastly different and and a game your first
one in the pwhl is I'm sure one that you will
remember forever I do want to ask you like what
is the next big step for the women's game we've
got the pwl now what do you hope can happen over
the next I don't know let's say five 10 years yeah
obviously expansion would be great of this women's
pro league uh the original six is a great place to
start and uh every game's competitive if you've
been watching and following along you'll see
that every game every team can beat every team it
just shows the depth within the league but I think
there will be opportunities to expand the league
provide more opportunity for players to play pro
um as well as bring it to New Markets and just
continue to grow our game with that the more we
can expand teams maybe we can have kind of like an
AHL for format on the women's side where there's a
little bit of a feeder system so if players aren't
ready uh to make that jump to Pro right after
college there's somewhere that they can still
develop that if their aspirations is to one day
play pro they can so that's kind of where I hope
to see it it might take a little bit longer than
five years to get to that point but that would be
a great place to grow to yeah helping create this
the pathways for other players to just get better
at the game and give themselves more opportunity
you know working in sports as a woman you know
these this League launches and just over the
course of my career I get asked a lot of questions
about what the impact I guess that it has on young
girls and I'm always quick to bring up well it's
about the impact on young boys too right that grow
up in a world where it's normal for women's
sports to be on TV for women broadcasters to
be talking about sports so that when they grow up
to be men it's you know not something to have an
opinion about or to even really discuss it's just
a normal part of their world and that brings me to
NHL Allstar Weekend I think it's super important
that you guys are involved in that you're going to
be in that three Onre showcase which I'm excited
to watch it's happening on the Thursday of the
weekend and for me it's like okay little boys at
home that are dreaming of playing in the NHL one
day are also going to be able to see you guys
put on a show as well what does it mean to you
to once again be a part of NHL Allstar Weekend
yeah so special NHL Allstar Weekend is such a
great event but to incorporate the women is a
whole another level of exposure um and like you
mentioned like it's it's equally as important
not just for the young girls we talk about the
young girls all the time but it's for the young
boys it's for people of all ages who might not be
exposed to the women's game this platform to have
a three Onre event incorporated into NHL Allstar
is you're going to get fans who maybe haven't been
exposed to the women's game that it's going to be
right there for them to see it so uh it's a huge
honor to be a part of the weekend I've I've been
a part of it in the past and it's such a great
opportunity um to meet a ton of people to get
out in the community so I'm really looking forward
to it it's going to be fun the NHL always does an
incredible job of including us incorporating us
and and making it a really special weekend for us
and a great showcase for for fans you mentioned
being a part of NHL Allstar Weekend in the past
what's the what was the feedback like um from
the male players that were at that all-star
weekend and have you heard anything from some of
the guys that are are going to be in Toronto the
same weekend as you yeah the support from the
guys in St Louis was the last time we had the
three on- three game for the women's and the the
guys were super supportive uh we we got to kind of
pass them we were in the same hallways of them in
the in the change rooms and the locker rooms and
uh they were really supportive of of our game it
was pretty cool to share the ice with them just
to interact with them get to know them a little
bit um and I know it'll be the same case here in
Toronto uh it's a great opportunity for us to kind
of interact with with with the guys at that level
I want to get to know you a little bit as well
obviously we know what your resume says but what
like what Drew rata fast to the game like what was
it that you know inspired you to play that made
you want to go to the Olympics like what is the
root of Your Love of the Game honestly I have such
a a a different path from a lot of my teammates
uh I come from a family who uh I'm the youngest
of four kids but none of my siblings played hockey
and my parents didn't play hockey no one in my
family really you know knew much about hockey but
um there was a a young girl the same age was me
when I was about seven years old who moved in five
houses down the street for me and she was always
outside playing Road hockey with her dad and her
brother and um I would always pass by and and be
so intrigued to what they were doing and uh I I
became friends with her she was the same age as
me uh we became best friends at such a young age
and I was like I want to do what she does so uh my
mom was like we don't know anything about hockey
we're gonna send you with their family to go get
you a set of equipment so they handed credit card
to to my best friend's dad and he got me suited up
for hockey and that's where it all started but it
really just started because I wanted to be with my
friends um and that's really been the base of me
loving the game of hockey all along as just the
people I get to interact with on a daily basis um
getting to interact at a young age with someone
like Becky Keller who at the time was an Olympian
that that's what kind of inspired me to dream for
the Olympics or even know that that that was an
option so uh a little bit of a different path
but I just feel like I'm always drawn back to the
people and the sport that make me love it every
day you know what I love about that story is yes
like many people play hockey because their parents
love it or played it or their siblings play it or
it's just you know Canada Canada's favorite sport
and all of that but I love that for you it was
like driving by kids playing Road hockey every day
and you're like this looks so fun like I need to
be involved in this road hockey game and it's just
that is like the core of of so much for Canadians
that play hockey is Road hockey mini sticks all of
those things that kind of come with playing actual
ice hockey as well so I love that story I didn't
know that about you so thank you for sharing that
um what are your interests outside of the game you
know you've accomplished a lot but what are some
of your other Hobbies or goals obviously hockey
becomes such a big part of your life and there's a
ton of avenues within the game that you could you
could likely stay in it for as long as you want
but um yeah there's definitely a balance Factor
you need to be able to have a lot of different
things in your life and uh I think what I love
in my off time right now is um I love to cook I
love to bake and that's what I do a lot of the
time in my off time uh being outside Outdoors
exploring so uh yeah just finding balance with
hockey at the same time and uh there's obviously
I know Avenues within the game that will always
be open for the day that maybe I stopped playing
hockey but can still be involved well you're a
very good speaker so if you ever wanted to get
involved in broadcasting I think you might have
a career path there when you're done playing uh to
say the very least but I love that you you you're
sharing your hobbies you like to cook you like
to bake baking is so much harder than cooking
like I try to bake and it is disastrous so if you
could give me one tip for baking what would it be
because I am I am a lost cause you got to follow
the recipe that's what it is cook cookie you can
be a little bit more creative throw whatever
you want in there but bakon you have to stay
the course all right fair you know what that is
my problem I don't often listen to the dire like
ah a little more of this a little more of that
it'll be fine uh it's never fine uh but that's
not the point um I understand that at these pwl
games in Toronto you do give tickets away um for
every game do you want to just tell us a little
bit more about that initiative yeah I'd love to
uh so as as Toronto was launching their tickets
and we got a sense that it was going to be really
difficult to to get tickets given the size of the
venue and uh how many people were interested in
attending games my age and I thought it would
be a great idea to secure uh four tickets uh
Seasons tickets and for every game I had the
opportunity to give it away to organizations
that mean something to me um and then ideally I am
depending on how things go I'm able to meet meet
those individuals who attend the game after the
game sign some things get some photos with them
uh so it's been a great uh initiative so far and
we're we're looking to grow it but we've worked
with uh the first one was black girls hockey
club so there was four young uh players and
they came and they wouldn't have had the ability
to come to the game if it wasn't for the tickets
as every game is sold out um I know there's my
Minor Hockey Association yeah yeah it's great
um I have like my my Minor Hockey Association that
I played with in Burlington growing up um I'm I'm
hoping to give some tickets to them um and then we
have like mlsc Launchpad here in Toronto so we're
just looking to to get some organizations that
you know are sport focused to hopefully bring in
some people who maybe haven't been exposed to the
game or the tickets are inaccessible so they can
attend they can enjoy it um and really just make
a really great night out of it well it sounds like
an incredible initiative so thank you for using
your platform already with the pwhl to give back
and try to help the grow the game uh in your own
way now I heard you say you mentioned Burlington
you're an Ontario girl I need to know like I'm a
Leafs fan I don't hide it are you you did you grow
up a leafes fan or what's what's your background
in that area oh definitely grew up a Leafs fan
and still am today okay so what do you think what
what do you make of the team so far we're halfway
through the season it hasn't been it hasn't been
perfect it never is for the buds but what do what
do you think of the team it's nothing new to
Leafs fans we're used to this um a little bit
of adversity here and there um but no I think they
have potential it's a process say you know we're
halfway through the season hopefully they can kind
of turn around for the second half but we always
believe we always believe yes Bleed Blue baby we
always believe you're going to see quite a few
uh members of the Toronto Maple Leafs in Toronto
for Allstar Weekend Austin Matthews on Pace for
like 68 or 69 goals or something ridiculous so uh
he's always fun to watch I can't imagine up close
what that shot probably looks like uh before we
let you go though congratulations are in order
you are a newlywed you recently got married so we
wanted to shout you out for that congratulations
how was the wedding where did you get married give
us a brief synopsis of the of the nuptuals thank
you yeah it was such an incredible day it's been
about three months that we've been married now but
uh we actually got married at my parents house in
their backyard my brother he owns an event rental
company so he was able to get the tenting and
the rentals and do all the decor so everything
really stayed in house in our family from the
planning and the execution but such a special
day to just kind of share with all our family
and friends a lot of te teammates were there my
husband also used to be a hockey player so it
was a lot of hockey players but it was such a
special day for us who wins one-on-one you versus
the hubby Road hockey let's say oh that's tough
that's tough he has a longer reach than I do but
I think I think maybe I'll take it I think I think
you could take them listen uh congratulations on
everything that's going on in your personal life
in your professional life have the best time at
allar weekend I'm going to be there so hopefully
I'll cross paths with you I can say hi in person
of course thanks so much looking forward to it
thank you so much rata I am so happy for you and
everybody involved with the pwl it is off to such
an amazing start we also have to shout out carder
heggy who made time not once but twice this week
thanks to all of my travel problems to make
that interview happen we appreciate you and
apparently watch out for Brandon Montour because
he'll prank you and you won't even know about it
uh I had so much fun this week thank you so much
for watching we are all out of time but make sure
you do all of the YouTube things like comment
subscribe and definitely come back next week see
you